any wishes for Drake Taylor Taylor takes
on Drake's 30th birthday bash in LA with
fellow squad members karlie kloss and
the Jaime sisters also in attendance
Taylor's famous folk Katy Perry who's
the reported inspiration behind a
revenge track bad blood and to make
things even more awkward John Mayer also
who went to the party let's not forget
he dated both Katy and Taylor in the
past inside Drake gets a sweet birthday
serenade from his dad Dennis well as mom
sandy gives the thumbs up earlier that
day Drake kicked off his birthday
celebrations on air it's the episode 32
ovo sound radio and it's a special one
it's my birthday the rapper premiered
four new songs for an upcoming project
called more life on ovo sound radio but
it's his new track called two birds one
stone that sporting some controversy you
would a man on the moon now you
those lyrics fans say are a major dig at
kid cudi and his ongoing battle with
depression he's also some things will
never change the rapper just recently
announced on facebook that he had
checked into rehab for suicidal urges
and give the context many fans feel that
Drake is being insensitive to Cudi
struggle with mental illness